I'm still having staff induced insomnia. I was told this would go away where the infection
was gone. But according to cultures, I've had infection three. I was stabbed for over
a month in off of antibiotics for almost two weeks. It's getting very slowly, better.
As I am up to almost four hours a night, the last few days, however I need more and better
sleep in order to heal. I never fall asleep before 2.30. And even when I go to bed at night
o'clock, I'll like you advice. And do not use electronics before bed, except listening
to my Bible would help try to fall asleep. I'm struggling with restless legs, which contributes
to the insomnia. I am using magnesium oil in my legs and doing some bedtime yoga. These
sometimes seem to help, but not always. Can you advise on both the insomnia and restless
legs? Well, restless legs, I know magnesium oil was a really hot topic about 10 years ago
when it first came out. Firstly, we carried it in our store. We used it on some patients.
I tried it personally. The problem is magnesium, minerals are in the form of assault. So,
minerals have to be bonded to something and the magnesium in the magnesium oil, I think
is a magnesium chloride. So it's assault. And it dries. And then you have assault on your
skin. So you have this white kind of salty layer on your skin, which can become itchy and
it's not really well absorbed. So I drew to be not a fan of magnesium oil. And I discontinued
carrying it and discontinued recommending it. Because I don't think it was shown to be well
absorbed at all. And I think the magnesium salt in a water is even better absorbed because oil
is not absorbed well through your skin. So I think taking magnesium baths in an Epson salt
is better for you as far as your absorption of magnesium and it can be more soothing to your skin
and you get less itch. So you still may have some magnesium salts on your skin after an Epson
salt bath. I don't think you get as much as you see the oil. That's just my tape. Secondly, so go back
to a question that an earlier listener had about restless legs issues. So making sure that there
isn't any other causes restless legs, which might have nothing to do with magnesium, might have to
do it by ear, might have to do it with other minerals, might have to do it with other things. Also
with the insomnia, there's lots of different beneficial herbs for insomnia that can help calm
your brain. You could try using GABA that can help calm your brain, knowing full well that GABA is
a large molecule. And if it does work to help calm your brain, that doesn't does indicate that you
actually have blood brain barrier issues. But a lot of people have blood brain barrier issues. And if
you're on antibiotics for that long and dealing with everything you have, you might very well have
blood brain issues. There's nothing wrong with using it to your advantage and getting GABA across
there, which is a call me neural transmitter. Using different using melatonin, if you're not using
melatonin can be beneficial using a higher dose melatonin, which can be good for cancer.
It might be beneficial. I tried to get some exercise before bed. I think I have a number of blog posts on
insomnia. And there's lots of different things on Google that you can find that can be helpful for
insomnia too. And I think there was one question there.